president trump and joe biden facing off
tonight
in their first presidential debate this
will be our first chance to see the two
men engage with each other
after months of sparring they're
expected to present two very different
versions for the country
yeah that's right you're looking at live
pictures right now of the debate hall in
cleveland where the debate will be held
people are already trickling in the
audience will be limited in size
due to the coronavirus and the pandemic
is sure to be one of the night's big
topics along with race and the latest
revelations
about the president's taxes among other
major issues ed o'keefe is inside the
debate hall in cleveland ohio ed good
morning to you it's unusual to be inside
a new building
not at home these days what are you
expecting
tony such a big deal i wore a full suit
today for the first time since march and
tonight is expected to be
one of the most anticipated political
events of the past four years it'll look
very different here in the hall
we'll get into that in a moment but up
on stage it should look quite familiar
and tonight is expected to be one of the
biggest television events
of the year i am looking very forward to
the debate
tonight after months of sparring from a
distance president trump comes face to
face with joe biden
i'm prepared to go out and make my case
as to
why i think he's failed the president
who's been campaigning nationwide in
recent days
insists he needs no preparation he
prepares for debates every single day
just by being president of the united
states and addressing the concerns of
the american people
trump campaign spokesman tim murtaugh
says they're taking biden's debate
skills
seriously in the democrat primaries he
just came through 11 debates and managed
to beat
two dozen opponents joe biden is a guy
who knows his way around the debate
stage biden is a longtime debate veteran
and he's been preparing from his
delaware home
his team is anticipating tough attacks
from the president potentially about
biden's son
hunter and his past work in china and
ukraine
the subject of a recent congressional
report a lot more
campaign spokesman tj what he should be
talking about
and what folks at home want to hear is
what is donald trump going to do for
their family that's what joe biden's
going to talk about
tonight's debate is set to run 90
minutes with six
15-minute segments focused on the
coronavirus pandemic
the economy race and violence the biden
and trump records
the integrity of the elections and the
supreme court
the court is a hot topic for voters now
just days after the president nominated
judge amy coney barrett to fill justice
ruth bader ginsburg's seat
campaigning in north carolina on monday
biden's running mate senator kamala
harris who sits on the senate judiciary
committee set to consider the nomination
didn't rule out meeting with barrett i'm
sure that's going to happen
yeah we'll see how everything works out
and do you intend to
i haven't made a plan one way or another
so
everyone here in the hall tonight is
expected to wear one of these medical
masks
except the two candidates and the
moderator we're told not to expect a
handshake or
an elbow bump from the candidates either
so that they can keep their safe
distance
there's also gonna be fewer people here
in the hall tonight maybe only about 80
to 100 down from the hundreds that
usually attend these things
but for those of you watching at home it
shouldn't look too different
anthony and once again in a full suit
for the first time since march a special
day ed
thank you very much big day you're never
fully dressed without a smile ed we know
you have one under the mask there you go